luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto
it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia higher pen
show today we are going to be talking about the
market bitcoin is finally back up at 46k which is
pretty insane so i'm very excited to jump in but
before we do this is of course um powered by icon
plus they are a vc firm um it is also sponsored
by block five so a huge thank you to them because
obviously without them i wouldn't be able to have
these amazing conversations um and before we
jump on and bring today's guest in um a quick
shout out actually to compass mining because this
particular episode is um sponsored by them and
this is basically the company that makes bitcoin
mining accessible for everyone all you have to
do is just buy a machine pick a hosting facility
and let them do the work so if you want to start
mining today then just head to compassmining.io
pretty great given bitcoin is very very expensive
to mine so they make it accessible so that is
fun all right so today's guest is danny scott
the ceo of the bitcoin exchange compass sorry
coin corner what's so much going on right now
coin corner welcome danny how are you doing hi
leah i'm good thank you hi so how's yourself
yeah i'm good i'm good so for those that
don't know much about you i do want to just
start by giving more background before we jump
into bitcoin um because you guys are a uk exchange
um this is such a us market so tell us a little
bit about you and of course coin corner yep um
so we yeah we are as you mentioned there sort of
a uk focus we're based in the allen man um we've
been around founded in 2014 um primary audience
market is uk um and always been the uk focus
um predominantly again focus on bitcoin um rather
than go down the exchange route we're more of a um
brokerage style coinbase-esque uh company um so
again it's a massive focus on bitcoin uh for us
here so we are more at the bitcoiners which
you can see the cushion to the corner of me
there apologies if people are walking past in the
background um we all sat in our office today um
so yeah i'm um one of the i'm the ceo and
co-founder of coin corner uh we were founded
back in 2014 as i mentioned there uh prior to
that i was a software developer by trade and then
um kind of found come across bitcoin through uh
various ways as you always do and i think you hear
about it a couple of times before you really pay
attention and started mining back in 2012-13 times
um played around with that for a while um until
the electricity costs here in the island mine got
too expensive um you have an interesting story
i want to hear more about that because i know
you have a really interesting story about that
okay the mining mine inside um yeah so yeah so we
started mining let's say back in in 2012
13 times um it was myself and one of the
co-founders of coin corner and we were mining
in his garage initially um so we were at first
kind of just hobbyist playing around didn't
really know much about it we had a software
development company at the time um and we're both
techies both geeks both into that side of things
um so we spent probably about two or three months
building up the farm and kind of getting bigger
and bigger and more hardware as we was adding to
it um and then it started blowing his electrics
in his house because it was in his garage uh so we
blew his electrics quite a few times there um and
had to keep scaling back to for some part and then
eventually we decided to jump into a warehouse and
start mining in a warehouse um we moved out
of his garage and went into a warehouse um
back in i think that might have been end of 2013
14 i can't quite remember the time and stuff
um and then from there we scaled up to a
fairly decent ish size um but then very quickly
asics kind of dominated the scene at that
point anyway and kind of killed off from an
electric cost perspective it just wasn't worth
it was over the time so uh being both software
developers by trade we decided to pivot into
the the bitcoin exchange side there was not
really much competition in the uk um it wasn't a
great mod it was it was obviously very early days
uh and the on-ramp for bitcoin exchanges in the
uk was was lacking um so we kind of jumped into
that side and we wanted to stay in the industry at
that point because we was interested and we kind
of moved that way excuse me um so yeah i'm sorry
yeah no i'm just gonna say your mining story i
know we've spoken about it before but it always
blows my mind i just i can't believe you know
the electricity was just blowing and things were
just it's just crazy would you ever mind bitcoin
again or are you just focused on the exchange
right now i'm focused on the exchange right now
but um i'd never say never i think the mining
side was certainly an easier business model um
but i think that was kind of we managed to during
the mining part of the process we managed to gain
banking relationships because of what we were
doing it wasn't quite as high risk as the exchange
piece so once we pivoted to the exchange you start
seeing lots of new uh eventful problems that you
come across banking being um probably the main one
um that we moved into so yeah maybe in the future
uh it's something i keep an eye on something that
in the element again the electricity costs are
too expensive for the most part but um maybe if we
have more the renewable sustainable energy that um
we do have certain things here that do that we
have a lot of wind farms around the island uh
so it's certainly an option but it's uh maybe a
bigger project than uh it can take on right now
yeah i know you're doing some interesting things
with um the isle of the authorities and the isle
of man or the government and the isle of man i
think that's kind of what you refer to them as
um but but we'll get to that but before i do i
think what's what really struck me about your
exchange was that you are heavily bitcoin focused
and it's such a um there's so it's quite a tribal
market isn't it you know the way people feel about
different cryptocurrencies and you've chosen to be
heavily bitcoin focused so what does that mean
for you guys and why did you decide to do that
um a number of reasons i think um the the main
reason i guess myself and some of the other other
members of the team we've always kind of we do
a lot of research into the industry and you know
i've been around the industry quite some years now
um and especially in the earlier days we've played
around with creating our own coin and playing
around with them sort of things we never really
launched and did anything it was just more of a
tech interest and playing around with the concept
um from that point i've always given the time of
day to altcoins as in to research and understand
them and understand their bigger picture in the
world and how they fit and how they're seen but
um bitcoin for me is still the de facto
cryptocurrency should we call it and bitcoin is
king um but it has the long-term sustainable model
shall we call it um altcoins necessarily most of
them um are not really they're kind of focused
on various niches if not trying to just clone
bitcoin at which point it's just just not worth
let's not go down that route with a minute um but
the way i've always seen it as bitcoin will be
the long-term one the rest of them are still
just a complete gamble in terms of their niches
and whether they find a market fit which they
may do in the future but um right now it's just
not there um so there was that angle of you know
i believe in bitcoin's long-term um lifespan so
at which point you know you want to focus your
business model and your business around the long
term rather than the short term um the other side
of that is kind of focus on doing one thing well
and where you have all the bitcoin exchanges like
your binance and um even cracking and um you know
even bit stamping the likes they all have expanded
into they're more of a trading focus platform
where we've always tried to hit retail and
keep it a bit simpler um with that in mind they've
all got trading as tools so they've got graphs and
all the numbers and all that side of things we've
stuck to a more simpler method um and trying to
differentiate ourselves from these guys you know
binance have added every coin you can think of
these days um why would we try and compete with
them when we feel as well and we believe that then
the the certain coins they're adding or the
products that are adding they're more of a short
term gain for a long term loss so we're looking
at maybe a short-term loss for a long-term gain
um so we're in it for the long term rather
than just trying to get in get out with
various altcoins um which i think everyone
kind of i imagine everybody would agree they're
kind of pumping dumb pest style coins
which are not really a long term viable
um so it was kind of there is a number of reasons
of why we've tried to focus around that um and
trying to build out bitcoins infrastructure and
help with that which is what we tried to introduce
in going corner with various products built
around bitcoin um obviously with lightning with
the cashback and uh the checkout um everything is
focused around bitcoin um being the core product
yeah let's talk about that for a sec because
you've got the cashback which is really cool
i actually downloaded the browser extension um
last week so i need to try that um but that is
really cool because it really just that's like a
direct competitor to lolly right but lolly isn't
available in the uk um so i guess just like my
question is why do you think the uk scene just
isn't quite what we see in the u.s like in the us
everything is just booming you know they've got
conferences they've got um most the companies
that you and i speak with are all us-based
why is the uk just so behind in that sense
like it just doesn't want to innovate does it
yeah i think i think there's um is it does feel
that way um and it does often feel that way
and even for us on the island man we're here with
um very small population and you know i can we can
literally every morning from our window just
over there we can see the uk and you know it's
right there in front of us so we're at stone's
throw away um even we feel distanced from the
uk sometimes even though you know we kind of sit
underneath it but then obviously from the uk point
you know we feel distance even further from the us
because yeah it seems to all be happening in the
us um i think a big part of it is it's definitely
silicon valley style so you know bitcoin is a tech
industry and it's a growing uh sort of booming
tech industry and that always comes or that's
always driven from the silicon valley side of
things um you know money from vcs is all there and
um there's a lot more money a lot more skill sets
a lot more uh talent should we say around silicon
valley or historically has been i appreciate
now there's a bit of a mass exodus from the um
so it tech and new brand new booming industries
always kind of drive from that side of things and
move them further afield so it certainly is always
a us driven industry and i think that's what we're
seeing with with uh bitcoin now on the crypto
side um i think obviously the us has a much bigger
population uh 330 40 million is it um you know the
uk has got 64 million i think is it around that
something like that so yeah we're kind of when
you think put things like that into perspective
you know it kind of makes sense that there's it
feels like there's more people over there involved
there is more people but the percentage-wise uh
i'm not sure of the the portions uh actually no
it's probably true the uk was about four percent
i think that we know of uk people population that
own bitcoin and i think the us is at something
like is it 16 or something yeah i remember that
um so yeah they're a little bit more um advanced
and ahead of us um as are some other countries but
then obviously other countries are way behind um
so yeah it's definitely the uk would like to drive
more products as you're saying they're like lolly
in the us um with the cash back and they were kind
of first movers i'm not too sure if there's many
other competitors there on that particular product
um at the minute but again they had uk we were i
think first if not i think there was one other but
i'm not too sure if they're still running kind
of a one-man band um and it is early days and
we're trying to drive the market by bringing
these products and introducing these products
um which hopefully we can do over time uh which
is it takes um it just it takes a long time and
it takes time to build and drive these products
whereas i think the industry feels like it moves
really quick when you've had altcoins icos
um nfts you know all of these things they
come and go very quickly and it feels like such
a fast-paced industry and it is but then the real
sort of substance products like keeping the cash
back side um there's a real substance to that
there is already cash back companies in the uk in
the us that are not bitcoin related but they do
the same product effectively but give you gbp or
us dollar back and there's a real substance there
in a real market um but you know that will take
time to grow and um people to adopt it i think
i think like what what concerns me is all the
hostility towards bitcoin um and just the and
cryptocurrencies are large really um i mean i
know the us obviously have the infrastructure
bill right now um which they're dealing with
which is a big deal um you know and the uk has
gone pretty hard on cryptocurrency regulation
i know the fca which for those who aren't
um english that's our financial conduct authority
they have started i think it's an 11 million pound
campaign to warn people about cryptocurrency i
mean for me that money would be much better spent
um on financial literacy that's another topic
um so so why why do you think they're going
so hard on it you know do you think this poses
a threat to anything you know let's talk about
like finance as an example you know they've had
they've now had their payments blocked from hsbc
nat west barclays those are three major banks
have you guys faced any issues like that yep
um i guess coming back to yeah the u.s thing i'll
come back to the yeah at least in a minute but the
us um with the infrastructure build been trying to
keep up to date with that um it's u.s politics and
it's you know it's absolutely chaos um it's for
me highlighting um to the world a little bit how
u.s politics is done and how these bills are
introduced is just not right there's something
fundamentally wrong with the system of how they
do that um there seems to have been obviously
this massive kick off about the crypto side
of things there and trying to get that part
of the bill through um or the bill as a whole
through but getting held up because of this
as far as i'm aware this bill has been has
been being held up because of the crypto
side so there's a big push back there within
this infrastructure bill there's lots of other
industries in there but maybe you know they're
not as effective or affected by it or maybe
they just don't have that community there that'll
push back and delay the bill like it has them um
for me i don't understand why they don't just
define broker you know it's all come down to
this one definition of the broker um they need
to just define broker as a bitcoin exchange
effectively somewhere where you can trade
cryptocurrency for a fiat currency and that's
the definition done and the rest of the if they
want to come and come back later in catch you know
they can't really catch miners and node um people
running nodes and things but you know if they want
to try and look to that or even the d5 side come
back to that in in time and make them amendments
um rather than the other way around which
they've gone up the way around by looks of it
um so yeah it's just is that incompetence though
in your opinion or is that like actual genuine
um disliking towards it i don't know how much of
a conspiracy needs to wear today i'm not sure um
i think they've they've certainly i don't want
to call them people it's easy to call somebody
incompetent um from the outside and not looking
sit in their position of what they're doing
um not defending them in any way whatsoever
because what they've done is terrible but
um they you know for something like that they
should have already reached out to the industry
experts or the industry as a whole and
gathered feedback before they introduce
it to the bill which they haven't done um so
that you know they should be doing that and
taking the advice and not just you know the advice
is being given now by the industry but they're
still just ignoring it and trying to get
the bill through and now that's part of
they want to get the bill through as quick as they
can because of x y and z or other external reasons
outside of our industry um so it's kind
of like that is politics in the us so
it's hard to to comment on whether that's
incompetence or whether that's rushing something
through um or on the other side of it are they
trying to attack the industry and attack um
maybe a little maybe not i don't feel like they're
trying to attack bitcoin try to be careful while i
say here okay i won't hold you to anything i don't
think they're trying to attack bitcoin as such and
um exchanges miners things like that i think maybe
you could argue that they're trying to attack more
of the defy side of things where they may start to
realize that they can't control certain areas of
that um although i appreciate most of the d5 these
days if not all is pretty much centralized in some
manner um so there's always a central point of
um choke that they can go to if need be um but
yeah maybe that that's a an angle for them they
can't figure out how to regulate d5 so you know
put a tax bill around it and um require
anybody involved in d5 to report to the irs
meaning that he'll probably scare most people off
because they won't want to have to deal with that
and the consequence of not reporting them things
so could be a tactical move um in that respect
i kind of don't really know um enough about
u.s politics maybe to um understand if this
is normal law or this is out of the ordinary so
yeah wait and see i guess i can't imagine the uk
and and following on coming back to the uk i can't
really imagine the uk at the minute particularly
starting to look to introduce something like this
i appreciate that there will be um tax reporting
requirements for bitcoin exchanges at some point
down the line to hmrc which i'm sure that will
come i appreciate that hmrc already reached out
was that last year or the year before to a lot of
uk exchanges asking them to report their clients
um but it was um again it's not a requirement at
the minute that will come in time i'm sure um by
the minute they're just i think the uk playing a
bit catch up with the regulatory perspective um
we've got the crypto register coming or here for
some part um and then i can i'm sure we can see
eventually um so the crypts are registered just
gives kind of an oversight of aml um on crypto
businesses uh it isn't effectively regulated um so
they're just you're just registered with the fca
rather than regulated by the fca um so eventually
i imagine they'll slowly migrate that into a
regulated by the fca which means they can you know
come and spot check you whenever they feel like it
and have more of an oversight into your operations
um so that will come in time but i think at the
minute this is just a stepping stone for them to
kind of gather them crypto businesses into one and
try and um weed out the bad bad players i guess
i think people know like the you know
authorities governments central banks
know the threat that bitcoin poses and the
industry as a whole poses and i feel that
they don't like it so for me i do feel that it is
somewhat intentional um did you see the news about
um the eu wanting to eventually ban anonymous
cryptocurrency addresses yeah yeah yeah i mean
number is that possible i mean what's up what's
going on with that um that was the the wallet one
wasn't there they were trying to yeah yeah um they
it's kind of all based up so faffer which is the
um global financial authority should we call it uh
they're the guys that try and um come at a global
perspective for the financial world and try and uh
dictate to um fat for registered countries which
most of the world or a lot of the world is um or
fall under faffer um fatfur don't make laws or
rules but they kind of dictate what the world
should do and they'll put um you know their
creator guidance should we call it and they
put guidance in place to say right you need
to act and do these things and then it's for the
countries to actually follow fafsa's guidelines
and introduce them into law and regulation um
but what we've seen obviously the last couple
of years with fatfer is they are trying to push
certain um cryptocurrency guidance out there
and part of that guidance um was something
called the travel rule and this these these
are still going on in the background this is still
happening um but part of the travel rule um was
effectively meaning that if a bitcoin transaction
left say coin corner and it was going to coinbase
for example we would need to know it's going to
coinbase and we would need to pass the information
over to coinbase of who this customer is
that's done the withdrawal from coin corner
to coinbase and let them know that it's you know
uh joe blogs has sent 0.2 bitcoins to you guys
um and they'd confirm receipt um and backwards and
forwards so if vice versa from coinbase to coin
corner do the same thing there's nothing out there
at the minute technically that makes that possible
um so there is people trying to build software
that'll be middle tiers that'll kind of allow
that and make that transaction happen um you
know there is uh opportunities for things like
lightning where um lightning you can create you
create an invoice and you can create and attach a
message to it so theoretically if somebody sends
lightning payment from coin corner to coinbase
um then we would be able to pass the coinbase
and be able to display that this is a coinbase
lightning invoice and we would know it is so then
we could pass the customer's information across in
the lightning invoice to them um as well so it
could be vice versa so there is certain things
in there that are slowly coming from a technical
technological perspective but they are still years
away and getting all the exchanges up to scratch
and integrated coming back to what you were
talking about there sorry on the yeah with wallets
and trying to ban private wallets on that side
um that kind of came off a little bit of the
back of the the fat for the travel rule and
trying to it's not like they're trying to ban
bitcoin and ban um personal wallets it's that
they're trying to help close close the loop
a little bit should we call it in terms of um
making sure that when we send so customer of
ours sends bitcoin out of our system we know
whether it's going to their personal wallet
or whether it's going to an another exchange
so we can make sure it's kind of like how
the banking world works i guess at the minute
and when you send a banking transaction it goes
to another bank and you know you know there's
a system in place there to pass the information
of who it's going to and where it's coming from
and so on um so they're just trying to wrap
something i guess the legacy regulation
around crypto at the minute um and that's kind
of the the battle i guess where we're at or in um
and trying to figure out you know how do we i
would love to be the whole you know we don't need
that side of the regulation and we don't need them
um sort of rules around us and we don't need fat
food to be dictating x y and z um which you know
yeah on some some part no we don't but at the same
time it's going to come so it's going to happen
regardless of what we want and whether we want it
and so we need to make sure we're meeting in the
middle which is similar to this infrastructure
bill in the u.s it's happening regardless of
whether people want it or not so you need to
sort of that's the part of the lobbying there and
trying to communicate with the regulators and um
you have to make them see sense for some of it
and um find a happy medium uh in between um so
yeah the eu side then they were never looking
to ban private wallets um it was more of a
stone towards maybe the travel rule side of things
and the flapper rules that are looking to come
in um we saw uh netherlands with the netherlands
about a year ago they introduced the law basically
they introduced that same thing which was the
travel rule so okay um dutch exchanges could
um if you were looking to when their customers
was trying to withdraw bitcoin if it was going
to their private wallet they had to prove
provide like a screenshot of evidence of where
it was going to and so they then did take that
to court and they won their their court battle
i think back in march it might have been this
year um which then has allowed them to scrap
that off now because it just wasn't workable for
the companies and it stifles innovation which is
exactly what it's done um yeah and we went through
um the crazy thing i was talking to a couple of a
couple of the guys um from the u.s side i'm from
the the dutch side when this was all happening
because it's happened in the us as well as there
was talk about back in november i think last
year um with a similar rule um and we actually
had this exact same thing in the isle of man
um back in 2016 i think it was and we worked
with the regulators here and explained everything
showed them you know we actually integrated a
automated process for a customer when they wanted
to withdraw their bitcoin they had to sign and it
was going to a personal wallet they had to sign a
transaction on the uh sorry they had to sign a
message on their address to prove that they had
the ownership of that address and so we automated
that in our system and did it as a try as a trial
um not because we wanted to it's because the
regulators were asking us to somehow enforce it
and we showed them look you can do something like
this on chain and we brought that in we trialed
it for like a month or two period and then we
gathered all information from that to show you
know how much this was affecting customers and our
business and everything went back to the regulator
and said look you're stifling innovation for us
here and creativity so if you're going to continue
to do that we're going to move and we're going
to go elsewhere um so at that point they were
happy to drop it we tried it we proved it just
didn't work and it would have killed the business
and they allowed us to open they'll remove that
rule and carry on as the rest of the world was and
so i think that was definitely that's a a a lesson
for um i think the us at the minute as well if the
u.s continue with the infrastructure bill and uh
don't make amendments the instructor bill doesn't
come into play until 2023 um okay gets passed
um but obviously there can be amendments made
from now until then that they'll hopefully try and
get through but if they don't get any through then
they're going to see a mass exodus of companies
individuals um leaving the u.s to go elsewhere to
develop um because it won't make bitcoin illegal
but it makes um effective everything around it
difficult yeah and it's just not worth it to
the individual to and if they want to continue
working on it or continue working the company
or d5 or software side they're going to move and
go to you know another country that is friendly to
crypto um so yeah it's at the detriment of the us
and introducing this really yeah i totally
agree with you i think that's the thing because
cryptocurrency is inevitable to me bitcoin is
inevitable this entire decentralized space is
inevitable you know even if we're talking about
like decentralized applications you know just
even down to that and surely the us would want to
be at the forefront of it you know like they're
at the forefront of everything um so yeah but
that's a really interesting story actually you
know that you um you went back to the regulators
and you said look this is just not practical and
they were happy to let that go i think that's
actually pretty amazing yeah i think it was
just it's kind of is communicating with them and
showing the real world example that we we had to
trial it for a couple of months to prove that you
know this would have killed the business um and
unfortunately we had to see it at the time and it
did stifle it and slow it down and the amount of
customer support issues that people were having
they didn't understand it was new technology it
just didn't work and i think even today that's
still that same process would still struggle to
work so um it's certainly there's lots of work to
do it's it is just education that the industry as
a whole is new technology is new and regulators
are not experts at these things and they need
the help just as much as everybody else does as
long as they're willing to accept the help and
and the advice to take on and hopefully um
introduce that in a workable manner for all
the companies and individuals around yeah i mean
you know just speaking of um they need help and
things like that i think was elizabeth warren that
sort of used bitcoin a doge in the same sentence
um you know i love i love a bit of doge like i
find it so funny like you know it's just funny
but you just can't compare the two you know um
no we we actually so we felt we we launched coin
corner back in 2014 with dogecoin did you yeah
we had bitcoin litecoin dogecoin i think it was
um but that was because you know it just launched
it was a popular thing at that time and we were
just launching and you kind of just go with
that and it was early days um but yeah it's
it's you can't it's just not a not a fair
comparison um of the two um yeah no so given
given all of this uh you know infrastructure
bill we've got um you know uh the fca in the uk
cracking down on cryptocurrency exchanges the
infrastructure bill like i said despite all of
this a bitcoin is moving which is so exciting um
i think right now i'm looking on finance and it's
at forty five thousand nine hundred dollars so
it's just under 46k very exciting um so i want to
get your thoughts on the markets you know we had
that crash everybody thought that was it china won
put it as bluntly as that um do you think we're
getting it is this the second wave is this the
second wave of the bull market what do you think
yeah i think so i think this um i've kind of been
uh hinting eye on on twitter for a while
with um i think some of the guys that doing
the on chain analysis side yeah he's really
good really good comparisons um i think the
for the most part most of it kind of correlates
and lines up with the history the historic 2013
and 2017 sort of runs you see a bit of a rise we
have a bit of down time and accumulation period
and then we start to go again for a second part of
the ball run the ball room generally lasts him for
you know between 12 to 18 months um time periods
um with the real spike probably um if history's
to go from it would you know be coming sort of
again november december time similar sort of
time periods uh this year um so i can imagine at
the minute the way we've seen it from history then
yes second spike looks like it'd be coming uh
the second run looks like it'd be coming um and
heading any time now from towards the end of the
year really um for a uh a sort of uh bull run high
um the so yes surely i've tried not to uh
can't give investment advice i haven't asked
you as generic as possible here um so yeah
i think that's definitely coming um the the
one thing the one difference um at the minute
from 2017 and 2013 that we're seeing today is
the bitcoin leaving exchanges so right the bitcoin
actually on the exchanges has been in a downwards
trend now for uh i think it's going up nearly
two years 18 months towards two years now um
that is always a metric that people do
pay attention to and keep an eye on um
and that's what you mean in people are buying
bitcoin on the exchange withdrawing it to their
cold storage will withdraw into
the personal wallets elsewhere
with that downward trend we've never seen that in
11 years of bitcoin's life and this is the first
time this is happening i appreciate those there's
arguments that say well you know there's more
bitcoin in circulation now which is why this we're
going on the downward trend um or um there's more
there's better infrastructure in terms of uh cold
storage devices and things like that which is more
which are more user-friendly so people don't have
to hold on exchanges and they can withdraw it and
keep it in a user-friendly manner and so there is
argue count i guess counter arguments to certain
things uh um but i think generally this downward
trend that we're seeing will create um a lack of
liquidity on the exchanges in terms of training
so one when we talk about um sometimes put this
out on twitter and you get a lot of people asking
you know what does this mean um so the the lack of
liquidity on exchanges as it's coming off as the
price starts to move again and it's moving quickly
there's not enough depth to hold up certain um
ranges so all of a sudden you may see massive
movements which we we have already seen this
year we saw big you know i think one day was
um did we have a 10k a day i think one day um 10
000 movement in day you know that historically
was yeah yeah i think we had one day which
was um a few months ago right yeah yeah yeah
it could have been after the elon uh elongate
uh the elon candle yeah yeah i think it was um
due to that um but that was like you know the year
before we weren't even at ten thousand dollars now
yes and thousand dollar movements in a day so
you know this is natural and this will happen
and you know going forwards ten thousand dollar
movements in a day might start to become more
natural you know if we're at two hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin then ten thousand dollars in a day
is insignificant compared to where we are now um
so so on that point i have to ask you then because
um people always talk about this um and
i get this a lot on tick tocks i'm always
like pushing bitcoin on tick tock obviously um
and people are always saying to me what kind of
currency is that right if it can move 10 grand
in a day what kind of currency is that what do
you say to that it depends on it depends on the
value of the currency at the time i guess um yes
yeah yeah yeah um i mean if if bitcoin's
worth a million dollars and it moves ten
thousand dollars a day it's tiny it's
it's negligible movement it's nothing um
so i appreciate the minute it's less for me would
focus on the percentage movement rather than the
value movement um the percentage movement is
still big especially when on the ten thousand day
um you know it's a twenty two percent of whether
it was movement i kind of figure um so that is
still a big movement for a currency and i think
people need to appreciate at the minute bitcoin is
still in its infancy and it's in um i guess
the way i see a lot of people see that is
bitcoin initially was you know this experimental
technology and it kind of grew eventually into
a speculative asset as as kind of where we're
going to now in an investment um eventually
obviously we're moving now people are treating it
as a store of value a long-term savings angle um
and then eventually longer term it'll start to
become as the volatility reduces it will start
to become more of a usable currency at that level
you know currencies are volatile every single day
around the world that they're trading backwards
us dollar to gbp you to euro everything else
they're all moving and they're still volatile
between themselves it's just that i guess the
country you're in if you're uk you're using
gbp you're you're not paying attention to
the gbp against you the dollar or the euro or
anything like that because it doesn't affect
your everyday life whereas with bitcoin you
are comparing it because it's a new currency
um so there's a slight different mentality
i guess you have to look at and think about
um when you're talking about the currency
movements and prices uh a simple question to
back to some of them might be okay so what did the
uh pound move against the dollar today then if if
you think bitcoin's volatile and nobody has a clue
because they don't really pay attention to that
um but it doesn't mean you know but i just do you
know no idea no idea who cares it's much smaller
percentage movements than bitcoin is right now
and that's because there's markets in place and
um world global economies that have been around
now for however many decades centuries and they've
um created some sort of stability in the markets
and that will happen with bitcoin over time but
we're still early and it does take time for that
to happen um so yeah there's no short answer to
that question i think it's quite a long-winded
answer uh i think for the most part yeah no i'm
with you i think you know ultimately we have to
appreciate that it is only a 12-year-old asset
and give it time everything you know it's it's i
look at it like a baby like babies are volatile
babies are screaming babies are crying doesn't
mean they're not going to grow up to be
excellent things you know still doing excellent
things right now that's not fair look at it
um but this bull market is interesting because
you know when we saw el salvador for example um
you know recognize bitcoin as legal tender that's
when bitcoin was low um and all the there was
a lot of bullish news coming out and it still
didn't manage to drive up the price um now it's
just sort of going i i wouldn't say anything is
necessarily sparked i would say this is the most
bearish from a let's say like a sentiment and
kind of like a like a news standpoint this is
the most bearish time that we're in given
all this regulation and all this uncertainty
and yet it's it's the price is going so what
would you say is driving the price right now
um all the things you've just mentioned
there with the el salvador okay delayed
reaction yeah yeah um that's the the momentum
takes it takes time for momentum to build up
and um we've seen that over even 2020 you know we
had a from the financial crash back in march 2020
um we then had uh the harvin and then we had
this this build up through the whole of 2020
of the price slowly grinding up the sentiment
changing towards bitcoin um that takes time and
we got to a stage where we got towards the end
of the year at 29 000 i think we were um and then
the new year came and it started to really ramp
up and start to move and then obviously we have
the spike and we die down again and we're back
to then accumulation period momentum building
um the good news is still coming but it it takes
time for you know we're in we i think we pay
attention to the industry far more than um the
most most people out there in the world so you
know we're living it day in day out so when we see
this news we're like why is nobody reacting to it
but you know then go outside our bubble and talk
to people and sometimes that you know they're like
they don't they're not even aware of like elon
musk accepting or tesla accepting bitcoin and
um they're not aware of them things
until you start telling people
even the paypal news of paypal now having bitcoin
on the platform you know people outside of the
industry still don't even know that and they're
not aware of that um so these things do take time
and the the momentum and the positivity and the
positive momentum that takes time to build up
and so i think there's combinations of a
variety of things that the momentum there from
the the external the retail market the world um
there's accumulation phases that obviously we're
going through the mining at the halving still
from just 15. still you think still yeah it's
all going to take effect so usually um the again
going back from history so don't don't say my word
for this one but if you look back in history and
2013 2017 and the harvin during them time periods
and the bull markets uh it takes between i think
it's uh 12 to 15 about 15 months on average um
around 15 months to go from when the harvin was
to the next cycles all-time high so you would
imagine then the next all-time high comes for us
around september october which is what i'm saying
now which is yeah this year um because that's
kind of like 15 months to 18 months after the
harvan um so the harbin takes time to kick in and
the effect to happen um so there's a combination
of so many things i think around the world
we've got regulation slowly coming in we've got
um the likes of paypal you've got banks getting
involved you've got everybody now you've got funds
etfs are starting to hopefully um sort of break a
little bit of movement there in the us as well and
i know further afield we've already started to
see etfs popping up and there all that side of
things is will naturally start to move the price
but they take time and then they will take time
you can see the etfs in the us have been trying
to get through for years three four years now i
think it is yeah i still haven't got the first one
through but you know the move there is movement um
so yeah it it takes time and it's a slow long-term
um look or view of the world rather than um the
short term trying to hope it's going to go to
200 000 next week you know you've got to take the
long-term strategy of these things appreciating
everybody wants to do that and everyone wants
to make a quick book in that angle which is a
completely different um argument or view of it
um so yeah give it give it time i think we'll be
getting there yeah it it's pretty crazy i mean
it's just constantly more and more news you know
and more and more bullish news which would you
know really give the industry more credit and you
know with incredible players like like paypal you
know tesla and all these players it really gives
the industry so much more credibility especially
when you're trying to speak to people outside of
our bubbles you put it um but what's always really
interesting to me is that is the tribalism but
i won't get into that really it's more just like
where we are going and what let's just say the
internet in general is going to be built on
uh because some people say bitcoin some people
say ethereum and there's that real kind of divide
between the two i know that you are quite there
i don't think okay okay i'm not gonna call you
anything but i know you lean more
towards the bitcoin side of things
i'm being polite i'm being nice no i'm joking
look like i think you know you lean towards
the bitcoin side of things so from your opinion do
you really think that what is being built on eth
right like defy dapps all of this stuff because
that stuff is inevitable that's coming will it
really be built on bitcoin can it be um i think
that there's so many different arguments um i
for me as i've talked about earlier on with
bitcoin being the focus you know i'm trying
to focus on on bitcoin sound money and trying to
create um the the future of where i see bitcoin
going there there ethereum is created to be
a completely different product and different
um a different niche a different market and
so they're going after a completely different
industry however they have tried to pivot
a number of times and now they're trying to
call themselves ultrasound money i think was the
latest one oh i didn't see that that's cheeky i
didn't see that one but you know it's they've
i mean they've changed their monetary policy
a number of times over the years due to they
think it should change the x y and z and they're
just automatically changing it and you know
bitcoins has never been changed and that's for me
um the solid foundation of what you're building on
so building products on a solid foundation is is
required and having this the not necessarily even
just the security aspects of it but you know the
in terms of mine and hash rates but in terms of
um you're building on something that you know
so ingrained into the the community and to
the world that you know 21 million bitcoins
are not he's never going to change and
and that's it and the mining and the um
new bitcoin coming in circulation is never
going to change and you know that monetary
policy you know how it's it's coming out whereas
with other coins and ethereum and so on you know
because they've chopped and changed and they move
around it becomes difficult to for me i wouldn't
be building something i wouldn't be building my
business and my business model on top of something
that could change at the drop of a hat because one
guy says so um so it it doesn't make sense from a
business model perspective or a long-term business
model perspective to build on them platforms like
ethereum and so on yet um a lot of what we're
seeing on ethereum is i guess uh research r d
trial and error people are trying various things
um we've had uh crypto kitties back in 2017 i
think that was we've had yeah um obviously
the nfts we've got all the d5 but um you're
seeing all the the rug pulls as people call it um
with various things once you know it's becoming
ethereum was as whatever's hot topic the wild
west building yeah they were building on ethereum
the hot topic side of it so the tokens was
initially the sort of thing and then um obviously
moving on to uh the cryptokitties and
the games and things that crash the
the network and it can't scale in the
way that it needs to to to create these
things um i'm trying not to go into too much
detail in trying to stay high level but um
the the short of it i think for me um with
ether i try not to uh abuse anyone building
things because there's lots of genuine people out
there building um the products of trying to build
products and do appreciate that but there's also
a lot of like you say there the wild west where
yeah um people are building for a short-term gain
on something that they know has not really got
long-term viability but they build it anyway to
throw it out there have a pre-mine of whatever
and run away with some money um bitcoin because
people are not doing that and people are building
genuine sustainable products and real world um
use cases we call it they don't have the budget
and the market money they haven't done an ico and
they haven't done these things so they don't have
that marketing budget to go and sell um to the
public so the public with the ethereum tokens and
so on you've got this ico money and you go in and
raise x amount x y and z i mean we've seen history
98 we're like 99 of icos now we're dead i think
uh well i didn't know um i think it was i think
it was nassau 99 points something percent of icos
now are all shut down um don't quote me on that
google and clarify um but it is a big percentage
so you can see they know they've raised money
they've thrown marketing out there people have
come in the founders have probably done very
well for themselves and they the product projects
shut down and disappear and you know that happens
in the real world and business and everything
as well but this was a little bit more wild west
than that i guess um whereas with bitcoin people
are building obviously with lightning and even
liquid and um you see them um impervious
at layer three now and you've got um
yeah the sort of uh sphinx chat and things you
know people are building them things without
even most of the world don't seem to realize but
you know that's where for me the real innovation
is happening and people are creating real
world products and real world use cases like
lightning now being able to be used for el
salvador yeah without lightning being there then
el salvador would have never adopted it um but
without bitcoin being the strong foundation that
it is with the hash rates and the uh long-term
sustainability trustability of the code base and
not changing monetary policy and things that is
what gives el salvador comfort that they can use
lightning built on top of bitcoin and drive that
way so yeah if i was going to build any form of
layers whether that's defile
or any other layers on top of
one of these i would be looking at a long term
personally i would be looking at a long term
strategy and for the business model i'm looking
to create and for me that would be building it on
bitcoin yeah um maybe not no i understand no
i i understand i understand i think for me
personally everything is so new so i'm yet to
see how everything plays out definitely have an
open mind about everything um but i hear you um
and you know you mentioned el salvador there and
that just sort of makes me just sparks my brain
a bit about again just regulations and all the
hostility towards it and just makes me laugh
really you know like a country have tried to
do something really incredible for themselves
you know if you look on google and it says
what's their currency it says us dollar and
bitcoin yeah they've got so much so much hostility
so um i know obviously we're tight for time now
but like just just want to get your thoughts
really why do you think they they receive so much
hostility um elsewhere like yeah um i don't know
from i guess yeah from the imf and that side
i guess that would be expected um that's um
a us perspective el salvador used their currency
as their primary currency um and then anything
like they're looking to move to bitcoin from
the us dollar or that they've introduced
bitcoin alongside the us dollar that threatens
the u.s dollar and that threatens the u.s power
and their control um so they're gonna get it was
it was um inevitable that they would get the um
backlash from the us and uh even the imf um and
i'm sure other places will give them a kick along
the way as well and that's something that they're
gonna have to deal with and then they should
will have known that from day one when they set
out to do that um i know there was a little bit
small parts of backlash i think from public um i
saw some of the uh was it in el salvador they were
um protesting i think for to not have bitcoin as
their currency really i didn't see that i think
there was it was made out to be something more
than i think it was because there was only i think
there was a picture of a couple of people doing it
and then i think somebody took a picture further
back and there was like you know 15 people
actually protesting not like thousands made
out so i don't think it was much more than that
um but yeah it's it's changed it's new uh yeah
the world disappeared i'm still here my camera
shuts off after 20 minutes i don't know why it
does that okay um yeah it's something new
something that the world's um trying to get
to grips with and the public are trying to get to
grips with uh the media is still spinning things
about you know negative conceptions of bitcoin of
uh criminal activity and money laundering and it's
anonymous and all these sort of things so with
all that in mind you know the public outside of
our industry i'll see in mainstream media talking
about these things and talking about the negative
side of bitcoin and you know the energy usage
and all these things so without the public really
going off and doing their own education on it
and their own learning they are just going to
take in what they're seeing in the media and
they're going to take that um perception of
bitcoin of what that is and they're going to spin
that and they're going to go and protest because
they've seen that it you know pollutes the
earth and destroys it boils the oceans and
and so on um which obviously we know is not true
but um media unfortunately uh helped drive that
i think that's just the way it is and it's gonna
be the way it is with any new technology or
any new movements especially in financial side
yeah and especially with something which poses
such an inherent threat i mean i was talking to
somebody the other day about donald trump because
apparently he might run for uh president again
in 2024 and you know he's supposedly anti-bitcoin
apparently apparently i had i don't know i don't
i don't think he's announced it but i think
that was just like a conversation that he could
run and i was like well that's quite exciting
for many reasons but anyway um so apparently um
people say oh no we don't we want we there kind of
get my words out we wouldn't want him because he's
not good for bitcoin but i don't think that it's
like he's not good for bitcoin i just think he's
like a us dollar maximalist and they understand
the threat that it poses yep yeah there's there's
a i think there's a documentary that's flagged up
to the team actually to watch the um petrol is
it petrodollar documentary or something oh i've
heard of it i've heard of it yeah it's just it's
only i don't know who's done it i think someone
in our industry has actually created it but um i
was going to have a watch of that tonight at some
point um just it's only 30 i think it's like 30
minutes long um so it's not too bad but yeah i'm
imagining that's going to highlight a lot of that
side of how the us dollar has its um dominance
and the war side and oil and everything
else so yeah be interesting watch maybe
yeah 100 i'll check that out but just
finally um i'd love to hear your opinion
on where you see the space in five years and i say
five years because five years isn't that far away
bitcoin is guaranteed to be booming in my opinion
um but you know what's the next hype but we've
had d5 had nfts you know this year we've had
institutional investors jumping in and you know
countries making it legal tender what's like the
crux of in five years time what can you imagine
um anyone's guess these days anyone's getting
um yeah i think from an industry perspective
it's difficult to say obviously we've seen
with the uh the nfts and the icos and the
altcoins and tokens and you know all that sort
of the defy side and so on that is potentially
literally literally anyone's guess i know the the
uh road maps we call it of like ethereum you know
they're trying to bring a lot of the financial
world onto um the platform as such there which
you know maybe that'll happen we'll see how that
goes um with the the bitcoin side um a big part of
going forward for me and my focus um going
forwards over these next five years uh is that
the layers kind of built on top of bitcoin which
we're seeing so your layer twos with lightning
and starting to introduce lightning into uh more
of a real world environments and use cases whether
that's just for payments whether that's um the
sphinx chart is a great example one so like
you know everyone's got whatsapp
what is that explain that to me
the sphinx chat is the spec like whatsapp or
telegram but it's it's every message you send
to somebody is a lightning transaction so it means
that it's encrypted end to end so there's only you
and the recipient that can read that message so
it's kind of like a decentralized whatsapp chat
built on bitcoin yeah and it's using all
the lightning invoice payments to actually
communicate and transact and uh talk to each other
um so that's like one of the first examples of
of that side we've seen the tlv which was a kind
of a an example thing from uh just jaeger i think
it's called um so he was again lightning kind
of developer and he created tlv shop which was a
website but you all of the payments and
the products and everything and your user
account was kind of controlled and transacted by
lightning so you wanted to buy a product on the
website you scan the qr code um for the to make
the payment by lightning and when you make that
payment in the invoice and the message
that you're sending across to the shop
you include your name and your address and
all the details so it means that the your
email address your password nothing like that
needs to be saved on um within the website with
the e-commerce company um you don't even need to
store your delivery address because all that's in
the lightning invoice and goes across to them uh
which can obviously be deleted and so on but um
that starts to remove away obviously credit cards
and cards are mass use online on online shops and
paying um and they're obviously arrive for fraud
and credit card for all the things so people get
cards stolen websites get compromised and your
details are leaked so it's starting to start
effectively move away but what we call pci
compliance in the card world so that's every
website that accepts cards theoretically has to be
pci compliant and go through all these checks if
you don't accept credit cards but you just have
bitcoin lightning payments and so on then you
can move the pci compliance um aspects away from
your your company um so you don't need to even uh
deal with that side of it so i think over the next
five years we're going to start to see um various
sectors or various products and and features being
slowly disrupted by lightning and the layer twos
uh and hopefully the layer threes as well um
coming soon which layer three is um kind of still
under wraps for the most part but there's
quite a few little projects now starting to
pop up which is um really interesting when i say
layer three that's just built on top of lightning
and so you've got bitcoin layer one lightning your
layer two and then you've got layer three which is
built on top of lining um which will start to
appear very soon oh i think it's so exciting i
for one really hope um we see more lightning
adoption and more education about lightning
because more people just need to be using it
to make the whole experience so much easier
instant fearless almost um and i think that will
change the narrative around bitcoin so much more
especially because a lot of the criticism is
often you know that it can't scale um i feel
lightning needs to prove itself on a on a large
scale to kind of shut that down um as well yeah
yeah hopefully el salvador does that for lightning
and proves that you know it works at a scale so
um fingers crossed that'll go smoothly we'll see
el salvador is a test i mean it is a test you know
that's what it is isn't it um but fine just
finally danny um what can what are the new
updates we can expect with coin corner you know
where can people find you um just plug yourself
and shamelessly plug ourselves um so yeah
coincorner.com um on twitter as well most
of the teams on a lot of the teams on twitter
um coincon and danny um you got molly zach dave
everyone else on there um you uh new stuff new new
side of things coming from corner this year um we
um do have cards coming soon um oh cards
eventually we're still um in in progress
with them um so they should be coming soon um
we have hopefully a new i'll say hopefully we
do have a new app coming soon as well um the apps
we do have an app at the minute but um in need of
a re-haul um and i think one of the big things
again uh we're continuing to focus on on the
bitcoin side um and the cash back and and the auto
buys and things like the features we already have
we're starting to try and um help i guess make
them more user-friendly and help on board people
like like yourself um trying to cash back out it's
something that a lot of the world don't seem to
know we've got there still and it's trying to kind
of push that out and help show people what we have
um in a nice easy cashback absolutely grateful
do your shopping online get bitcoin back for
percentage of whatever you shop um and obviously
that's just over time adding an adding and it's
like a savings account effectively for a long
term um strategy so dca and while shopping
dca and more shopping i love that i'm so excited
about the cards i love a good crypto card like i
have too many i love them all and they're they're
all just slightly different you know whether it's
earning interest or if it's cash back or you know
they're all really cool um but yeah i want to
thank you so much for coming on it's been really
really interesting learning more about um you
know what you guys are up to and just getting your
perspective on the markets right now because you
know it's it's a confusing time some people say
they know what's going on some people have no idea
so it's always good to understand more yeah i
have no idea i said this the other day i was
like i was like do you know what if somebody tells
me that they actually know i don't believe them
yeah officially thank you for having me on
there appreciate it yeah absolutely and thank
you so much for my sponsors block by luno and
compass mining and of course icon plus capital
guys don't forget to tune in next week for
another brilliant guest we'll see you then bye